Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
When I was growing up, IQ tests were created
by humans to test the intelligence of other
humans.
If someone told me just 10 years ago that
algorithms will create IQ tests to be taken
by other algorithms, I wouldn’t have believed
a word of it.
Yet, just a year ago, scientists at DeepMind
created a program that is able to generate
a large amount of problems that test abstract
reasoning capabilities.
They are inspired by human IQ-tests with all
the these questions about sizes, colors and
progressions.
And then, they wrote their own neural network
to take these tests, which performed remarkably
well.
How well exactly?
In the presence of nasty distractor objects,
it was able to find out the correct solution
about 62% of the time, and, if we removed
these distractors, which, I will note that
are good at misdirecting humans too, the AI
was correct 78% of the time!
Awesome.
But today, we are capable of writing even
more sophisticated learning algorithms that
can even complete our sentences!
Not so long ago, the OpenAI lab published
GPT-2, a technique that they unleashed to
read the internet, and it learned our language
by itself.
A few episodes ago, we gave it a spin, and
I almost fell out of the chair when I saw
that it could finish my sentences about fluid
simulations in such a scholarly way, that
I think, could easily fool a layperson.
Have a look here and judge for yourself!
This GPT-2 technique was a neural network
variant that was trained using 1.5 billion
parameters.
At the risk of oversimplifying what that means,
it roughly refers to the internal complexity
of the networks, or in other words, how many
weights and connections are there.
And now, the Google Brain team has released
Meena, an open-domain chatbot that uses 2.6
billion parameters, and shows remarkable human-like
properties.
The chatbot part means a piece of software
or a machine that we can talk to, and the
open-domain part refers to the fact that we
can try any topic, hotels, movies, the ocean,
favorite movie characters, or pretty much
anything we can think of and expect the bot
to do well.
So how do we know that it’s really good?
Well, let’s try to evaluate it in two different
ways.
First, let’s try the super fun, but less
scientific way, or, in other words, what we
are already doing, looking at chat logs!
You see a Meena writing on the left, and a
human being on the right, and it not only
answers questions sensibly and coherently,
but is even capable of cracking a joke.
Of course, if you consider a pun to be a joke,
that is.
You see a selection of topics here, where
the user talks with Meena about movies, and
the bot expresses the desire to see The Grand
Budapest Hotel, which is indeed a very humanlike
quality.
It can also try to come up with a proper definition
of philosophy.
And now, since we are scholars, we would also
like to measure how humanlike this is in a
more scientific manner as well!
Now is a good time to hold on to your papers,
because this is measured with the Sensibleness
and Specificity Average score, from now on,
SSA in short, in which, humans are here, previous
chatbots are down there, and Meena is right
there, close by, which means that it is easy
to be confused for a real human.
That already sounds like science fiction,
however, let’s be a little nosy here and
also ask, how do we know that this SSA is
any good in predicting what is humanlike and
what isn’t?
Excellent question.
When measuring human-likeness for these chatbots,
plugging in this SSA, again, the Sensibleness
and Specificity Average, we see that they
correlate really strongly, which means that
the two seem to measure very similar things,
and in this case, SSA can indeed be used as
a proxy for human likeness.
The coefficient of determination is 0.96.
To put this into perspective, this is a several
times stronger correlation than we can measure
between the intelligence and the grades of
a student, which is already a great correlation.
This is a remarkable result.
Now, what we get out of this is that the SSA
is much easier and precise to measure than
human likeness, and is hence, used throughout
the paper.
So, chatbots eh?
What are all these things useful for?
Well, remember Google’s technique that would
automatically use an AI to talk to your callers
and screen your calls?
Or even make calls on your behalf.
When connected to a text to speech synthesizer,
something that Google already does amazingly
well, Meena could really come alive in our
daily lives soon.
What a time to be alive!
This episode has been supported by Lambda.
If you're a researcher or a startup looking
for cheap GPU compute to run these algorithms,
check out Lambda GPU Cloud.
I've talked about Lambda's GPU workstations
in other videos and am happy to tell you that
they're offering GPU cloud services as well.
The Lambda GPU Cloud can train Imagenet to
93% accuracy for less than $19! Lambda's web-based
IDE lets you easily access your instance right
in your browser.
And finally, hold on to your papers, because
the Lambda GPU Cloud costs less than half
of AWS and Azure.
Make sure to go to lambdalabs.com/papers and
sign up for one of their amazing GPU instances
today.
Our thanks to Lambda for helping us make better
videos for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!